Hello my name is Monica Diaz and I am going to have a conversation
with Nooria Nodrat for visible lives oral history of the
disability experience a project of The New York Public Library. Today is
November 19, 2014 and this is being recorded at
Nooria's home.
And we'll get started, Nooria, can you tell me a little bit?
about where you come from?
First of all, I want to say thank you for the opportunity
for...to come here and visit me and give me the honor
to share my stories to other
people individuals, and give them the strength
and energy to go on with life. And also, I want
to extend my appreciation to library for the blind as well as
the Library of Congress and public library for such
opportunity. I am originally from Afghanistan. I came to United
States in 1991 as a ?? refugee with my
father and my rest of my family.
I had a glaucoma in the past. But I was stable with
medication and also using glasses. I was able to read regular
print. Umm, however, in 1997 I
been attacked. By a teenager at the subway in 34th
street and 6th Avenue in Manhattan. And
she was in high dosage of drugs and then been and
mentally disturbed. So I guess she took me as
a wrong person or hallucinating. And she
punch over my eye in my head. And because of that incident
I become totally blind overnight.
But life is always going on. We all have a choice in
life. We can make our life.
I have two choices in my life. I think one was to hold my
knee and cry and feel sorry about myself. And the other
one to let it go and to forgive that
individual who hurt me because I'm...I believe she
was not ? her mental stages to
realize what her reaction will cost me.
So, I'm hoping that she will recover, from her illness
and be a positive individual. And then I let it go and I
continue with my life and then so far
I'm doing
doing well (laughs) I'm...thank you...I'm
now I...uh, this year I graduate
from CUNY School of Professional Studies.
It's a program under the graduate, CUNY Graduate Program.
I got my M.S. in disability studies.
undergraduate was at the New York City College of Technology.
I
I, um, graduated in Human Services, um, in
Social Science, um, in two thousand nine. And in
the same year 2009, I established a
nonprofit organization. That is called Afghanistan
Blind Woman and Children Foundation. And
this foundation support blind children from elementary
to graduate high school. And also, we have a the rehabilitation and evaluation
services to evaluate client base of their capacity of
knowledge and understanding. And also, their physical strength to see if they are
qualified to go to college or pursue work.
so, um, we find for them job or if they wish to go to the college
we send them to the college and pay for their college expenses. We
also help plan women who has, uh,
health issues, whether is if it's mental health or
physical health issues. We send medicine
we send money for the prescription. We send money for the M.R.I.
or anything else.
. We also particular help them with a chronical disease
such as tuberculosis, HIV, or diabetes,
heart disease you know is very threatening to.
people lives. So we try to help them on that.
Umm.
But, my background...I, uh, I born in
Kabul, Afghanistan in Nineteen Sixty One in a
middle-class family. My father was Vice Minister of Board of Education
in Afghanistan and education was very very important
and valuable to my family, especially to my father.
I have...I have five siblings
and my older brother
his name was (inaudible). He was a totally blind individual
but he was very bright and very, um, smart
individual. He knows into 8 international languages and all.
And during the Dark History of the
of Afghanistan, where he was in Pakistan,he wants
to.
Open a school to, to help and
support blind people in the border of
the refugee campus between Afghanistan and Pakistan. So
he had to go to have permission from different
uh, group, of Islamic groups in
Afghanistan to open this
school there and one of
them capture my brother and accusing him that he's a
CIA agent and he's inviting
people with Christianity. And so they captured my brother
and then they execute my brother so...
My brother and I was very close because of you know I have a glaucoma and my brother
was blind too, so we have a bonding there, very deep and I'm mis him
terribly. Every time when I'm talking about him I can't hold my
emotion,but so
I decided to pursue my brother's dream by having this
foundation to help.
To help blind individuals in my native country.
And I'm very, very fortunate. I have wonderful board members
and they are very supportive of me and my work. And
.
I do...thank thank. Thanks
I know it's difficult for you to talk about your brother
i know you had some
fond memories with him. You know, how did that, how did that
experience help you launch
your organization here. You know, what are some things that you brought with you based on
based on that experience.
You do a lot of other work outside of you organization, but how did you like that Afghanistan, kind of
impact what you are doing here. Well every incident and individual I
has impact in it, whether it's negative or positive.
I guess the hardship (clears throat) that
I've been through, through my life
I guess gave me in abroad that impact that turn
turn my life around and become a positive individual and think you
know that life is not always bad, you know? You just
you can, you can, you can choose your own destiny. You can make it
possible. I, I don't want to say it's easy.
Of course not, you know everything in life even when you are as a human being
be breathing to survive that's work, right?
In order to get inhale and exhale, to get oxygen and
nitrogen and carbon monoxide so they all (laughs)
like work.  But we all must do it and
I believe my experience in my life lead me that
I have to do it. I just must do it. I can...being
in awe of being just take care of yourself and being just
eating sleeping and think about yourself. In my opinion
cannot make good and a complete human being you have to
you have to contribute something in your life you have to give something
. So and I'm very very glad that I am
in a country that I have so many opportunity for woman
for people with disability we all have a right see here we have all have
a dignity but in a country like Afghanistan the.
Disability always heading behind the walls. This
opportunity is very limited. And I.E. it will
be honored for me to pursue my brother's dream and pursue my
own good aim to want to help this woman in
Afghanistan. Afghanistan has four hundred thousand planned
population which is two point five percent of the
entire country population and they have only one blind eye school
from elementary to graduate high school. India and all the entire country and
this school has only two hundred students. So compared to that six
this sticks that four hundred thousand people two hundred
students or nuffin. And I want to really help these people
and also in all the.
All entire country have only one bill and why
only one eye hospital and all the entire country.
So and that's in the capital of Afghanistan in Kabul
and the rest of the regions in the country they don't have a they don't
have a hospital at all so they have a they have to go to see a
private doctor there and that one is only available on the
C.D.'s So in the village and in our area
there is no nothing there. And that's a cause of
blindness. There so I'm trying to change that I'm
trying to if you know that's my dream to one day I will be able to
provide a you know I clinic somewhere beside the Kabul in
another state or a region of Afghanistan so they can to
see if I care or they can receive other medical care and
that's that's why women are always
in Afghanistan are in there. In the second
level of the societies a man is always that dominant their
leader and his woman is always a follower
and if you are being bored then if you are blind and you have no education no
work no nothing and being a woman and staying behind the wall
and nothing to do and you must follow the
order and say to you don't do this didn't do that.
How frustrating how difficult and stressful
life is for those but I know a lot of them are struggling and suffering
from mental and depression because they can do anything
they want to be free they want to. I'm sure they have the same feeling as I have my
you have because they are woman you know and they are like us they are not
different I mean biologically or a lot of are but they cannot
do it because they don't have the ability to do it I want to give them the
tools so they will be able to become free and do something for
themselves and this is this is my experience and
I when I was in Afghanistan. Woman. In The
Blank woman in our denizen weren't allowed to have a cane
walking cane to walk alone. Because
society's not ready for it right now.
Yeah. Their families their families they have to somebody has
to hold their hands and take them to where the year end there or the
doctor that was there or not staying there for all of the
home. We couldn't do anything and they go out they will
stop and then they will pull in all of these
terrible culture. I'm sorry to say that I mean I love my country
but I see it every culture every country has a positive culture native
culture and this is one of them and talk to people with disability. Woman couldn't
walk there because this stone the stabbing the shooting
the film on them they heard them in all of the was a woman she
has two kids and she was blind and she
has to give and she has nobody except ourself and her two kids.
So she was walking holding Cane one child holding her
skirt another witness on her arm and she was carrying can walk and
this throw this stone on her and they hurt her forehead you know.
So this is this is and this is stemming for lack of
education because they are educated they know the
value of human human being know the value of woman do you know that
their respect and dignity for people with disability. Unfortunately this
forty years of war and four generational war didn't give
anything to have been people except to hold again and shoot
and two countries
. No no I mean I want to
know all that you know the circumstances not that they'll vote for me
and my my father's kind of concern
because my brother lost his life and he doesn't want to lose me
so you.
Know it's there about how your family has supported
. Your your goals in your dreams.
I'll play my I'm very very fortunate
. And then come with the sort of family my father and
my mother. They make sure that I raise right
and then my father my brother who was blind so they don't
have any issue with my blindness on what one father my brother blindness.
But in all my flight that I was the only one to work with the
family and bring enough food in the table and support the
children and my mom and my mother was a housewife because
six kids and she couldn't make it to go work and do things
and my father was spending most of our long hours I was life
working hard. You know even though he was workin after work
hours after five o'clock to stay in the office and do all in because he was a
minister of education and his job was require a lot of work
so he must stay there and. But both of them are
wonderful parents and I am my own mother passed away in one
thousand and two thousand and nine. Yeah I think you know I
miss her a lot
. She was she was. A GIVER. She
just won and gave and gave and gave and never complained. I guess I
get that. I don't know.
But did both Americans of my father's very very. And when I
was young he was very over protective of me. But now
he knows that you know I am not
. A perceived or hopeless person
. So. He let me go.
But he still wants me to call him every day in the
morning and evening it hit him I'm home I'm safe everything is
fine is is
he's wonderful so I'm also I have a brother all my
family my sister is my brother my older
brother you know who lost his life so they all are we all educated
so. My. Younger brother he get to his master to be
masters and one is in agriculture and one in
psychology in business another one is in computer the youngest one is
younger than me and my oldest brother was
is two months and one was in law and the other one was in
psychology and education enough and one day he was fine
in languages. My sister was a teacher. My older
sister my young and consistent was a teacher and my sister was a
teacher and my sister in law my brother why he was a
teacher. She's a teacher so. And I think
a show has you know something. It's make a lot of different people
behavior and I guess from an education and that my family to
become a positive to people with disability and to me
and my brother who are disabled in the family so
I'm very very fortunate on that. Yes I'm a little I
lost my husband in ninety nine and I have two
children and my son is
here. He's in Sydney Australia and he's a computer programmer
and technician and he's doing very well and so I call up talk
to him and I visit him in two thousand and twelve. And for a couple of
weeks my daughter she's married she lives in
Pennsylvania and I have two beautiful gorgeous
grandkids. My granddaughter name is Michelle
and she is she will be nine
and my grandson his name is
Omar. And he is going to be five. So
. You know and my my children OK
you know my children are wonderful.
I'm very blessed in the Victorian. They don't have a good day.
I'm so grateful with God to my family especially to my brother my
dad because raising a child being single parents and
being blind is not an easy task but I have the support of my
family especially my sister and my brother
. They always been with my kids they love them very much
so and my daughter right now she's.
For saying that her college to finish and to become
a geologist so she's worth
studying though she couldn't study earlier because of kids of knowledge or
Fitz's grew up so she stuck to go to school you know
. So kitchen has an
impressive accomplishments. Yes and it is a very important thing.
How do you how do you bring that into your organization. You know you
mentioned to rehab. How has how
do you how established. Yeah it's only a little bit more about your you know the or
in this show.
I'm I'm part of trillions International
. Call out for people with disability
to pursue their social activities or running walking jogging whatever
and I was doing my training in two thousand and four two thousand and
six. And one of my colleague Emmy
my A volunteer is she now we talk in one of the when we
were training and she heard about me and she told him about how his friend
and he is in a movie documentary movie
producer. Then he got interests to come
in and have a documentary about me and my life.
So we complete the documentary and the night of the
opening night of documentary I stand up
and I asked the audience that I am really
desire and hope and wishing to stop machine
profit organization to support children.
And their idea and it was very generous that day and the
same night I raise eleven hundred dollars. I just asked them to give
me two dollars and the people who are wonderful so I took this
money in my hand and I went to my college while I was doing
my undergraduate at that time. I speak with the head of the
Department of my college. Justine political witch and she was the
chairperson so I thought all right this is I have I want to this is
my dream and I have this money so I don't know if you can help me
to where I can go all I have no idea how I'm going to start it but this is
the way I have the big big big dream in my hat and I
think she told me OK let me talk to the president of the school and see what they can
say. So the he. And she was able to speak with the president of
my college
. And fortunately we have in my college they
have the one of the law former attorney in our
board in their board member. So that lady was that
caused to connect me with the poor borna law form
and then to the months I was able to establish again some blonde woman and children
foundation. I you spend that elegance and there are dollars to pay
for all the legal paperwork and I'll. Finish it.
And I. When I went to when I went to the attorney
they told me you need to have. People to be your board member we need
a new message or no problem. I didn't.
Think too many people name these he said laughing at
me. This is you have a very small. You will have a very
small organization you can you can have a twenty eight people on your board
.
So you need to have me started maybe from you know four to
eight people and then then later on you can increase its
up and then I choose the best people there and
then. So one of them is one of my board
members a Dick Traum. They have the Victory's International
. So he's very supportive of me and my work and
every year I reraise and I do manage
. To raise money for the foundation
so I last month in November.
In the beginning it was yeah I finished my
ten monotone.
Before before this month on I write
I mean since two thousand and ten I raise money for that for my own
foundation. But before I was raising money for different charities
I raise money for cancer research is more magazines and raise
money for it please.
So different that was my goal because I choose
mandatory for exercise and socializing and all but I
realize I can offer my. You know I can give something back
if I do that.
By involving charities so desolate
and is
this organization your answer. Yeah yeah. How do you
train for hours.
Well usually during the week I can't do it because I'm
too book but usually I do on Friday night
.
I put you know my my e-mail
. I believe now and.
So you. Mentioned you
treat you right. It's quite a few.
How do you train and don't do
. Unfortunately I'm not available to do it
because they have to C N N SATURDAY
MORNING. They know they work out but I
can make it to join to the club hours because of my
Daisy's crazy schedule I usually
do I send the email to to the Facebook
or the board to the they called Blackboard in
the IT please and then I posted my requests I say
I'm looking for a while until a new one wants to work with me on Fridays.
So the afternoon Sunday afternoon Sunday morning and during the weekend
I do my training mostly.
You know you talk too much about the
figurative snake nineteen
.
Oh how do you make that transition.
You did after
she attacked me. There was a lady she and a
passenger she came and she told me you need to go to the police
. And just one thing I want to say you know being
an immigrant from other countries not knowing the law well
that's a little happen. I thought OK I'll be fine. I'm
you know I just I feel you know as I have asthma and very severe
asthma that I have to take medication. And number later
in all these steps to follow her as my
patient and you know asthma has a direct
connect in contact with the nervous system. So when you
become you know I was here as well as other they knew more. And I was
.
Being on my asthma that I'm raising and like death and
the conductor of the train. He came and said to me now you
came inside Iraq a mess and I was like that he thought that I'm saying yes I'm
fine
. So he he chews my vulnerability as a whore
yes and he took the lady put it in the train and he left me there
without any assistant in a ding so the lady told me to go to the police and I
ignored that I guess I wasn't aware of it I didn't have the
knowledge of it and it was you know it's important to know the
law or the culture of the thing of it Candy that
you're living in and I don't know that because. I
was new I came in one thousand nine hundred ninety one and one thousand nine hundred ninety seven I lost my
sight so I went in to night when
I was in the morning when I woke up I feel everything dark it
was dark side thought is not a night day yet
but I don't do it and I don't see it like there. I I thought
maybe the ball is the light poles of so I reach my
hand and I feel the warmth in it and I realize
and I was that's it I thought to myself I scream like a
animal and my sister and my children they run they rush they came and
said what happened I said I just told him I can see it because everything is dark ear
what happened so they took me to the emergency room
and the doctor told me that I'm late I'm too late because what happened when
she punched over my head in my eye and the retina
of the nerves that sent
messages to the brain to see is completely damage
and because I have a goal a coma and the pressure of the
eye is just not the condition of the local mother
pressure of your eye always going up. And this killing every
nerve as it is going up. So because she put the pressure on my island of
punchy and depression my and I went up and that's why it caused to
stride the whole Gretna and then it wasn't impossible to
fix it. I did five operation and everything I did I
say OK let me maybe I will have a little bit might have a little bit site and but
it didn't work and because of this all
operation especially in one of my operation I think it was the fourth
one fifth and they the remember the put the guess he
called Bubble oil gas in my
eye to make direct enough for that so I'll be able to see it.
But that early on that. Oil gas caused
infection in my eyes I was in stream pain and
being on my undergraduate and this college it was so hard for me
to focus at my studies and on the side I went to the doctor I said tell me
that through that I'm going to have my side they're not interested they say we cannot
see as we cannot say no I say no you have to at least give me some
some you know. Answer I need to know and then he
said to be honest with you we don't think so you've been a hobby of sight because
either you know or rather not it's really deteriorated you know and there is no
possibility to fix it. I says it will if is not then please
and I want to remove this lie is really hurting me I have so
much pain I can do with it I will stake in time
no not could be wife three or four times per
day and still I was crying and measure pain and
all my face the wrath of the rash here all around my eyes. All around
my eyes and burning like hell so I was and that's it and
I had. We. Decided to remove my my my parents
only not to do it. Everybody said you know I said if it's meant to be
be blind they're meant to be. You know just just
let it go I can I can do that. So I remove my eyes in two thousand and three
and then and then I have a press that it right
there looks nice beautiful you know and they are like it
like that they call it smoky green color.
So and this much my comments come complection of my skin and
I'm happy with it. If me
. Psychologically
I was scared so much when I was
lost my sight on the first week or will probably do a couple of days
when I'm one pulling my step in one put Nick's next
foot to the next when I was screaming and put him back and say
to him what happened. No I'm going to hold out I'm going to fall down I couldn't
courage myself to walk one step forward. Because I was so scared
and my sister. I love her I love her very much.
So she my older sister she came and she put
our hand in my hand in her shoulder and she put in the front of me she said No
You see I'm walking I'm following you just put follow your
footsteps see see I'm not following. So you're not going to follow
. Just just go ahead and go it and I did that and also I
went to New York Corvallis photo and I asked for
therapists and
. Therapy you
know psychotherapy and also I received a lot
of you know and training mobility training from commission for the blind
and other organization had the Jewish kid the gilded
than I preparing myself in the most important thing I think is
changing me is the decision that I made for myself
. It is to not to to
just. Accept my disability wherever
I am.
My disability is not going to change but I can change I
can adopt adjust myself to the my new circumstances
.
And that's why I. Did so.
This street. Between
the parties. Challenges you faced in you know where we were
. Where did you get support from your community
.
I mean. I see and I see first of all my
family support a lot and I also received support from
you know social services for a commission
for the Blind which I'm forever grateful.
They've been very very wonderful people and helped me so much and
. Also participate in
many different activities. I saw her karate
yoga ceramic move Zeke and her writing
class and I took it Clarice. So
those social activities even there was a purpose is just to
keep myself busy is give me also another
perspective which is I learned skills I I know
the site. Be set right now as a
social service or a human service provider is is good to know how to
do yoga technique. So I learned that because of my social
activities. And I was in a karate
class and one of mine. I
recently lost my sight that time and then you have to go for
permission. I'm an Advent C.L.O. belt in karate
so. When I am in there I was crying for my inner to do that in
my to give my new key because you have to do it certain exam
tests they do. My mind
structure. His name was Patrick bright brown He was
a fireman. I did nine eleven and he
lost his life there. He was you know I always say to
me. Nuria you think you are the same new
area you are in society we are the same no enough and chain you just lose your sight
that you have the right. To who you are inside of you
don't know that you are just vision destroy you and discourage you from
your work if you if you fall.
Seven times stand up for the eighth time and try again.
Never let yourself to be down but I follow
this instruction I guess I passed my promotion and I got my
new belt and all but this world of this my instruction.
It's still. Haeckel in my brain always if I feel
down. I'm thinking about him and that's helped me to go on with
life. Some people you know you just don't know if you just bring this so much
influence in your life and just simple word Nic a
different individual way. And then I start to continue
my college and I got my dog I had a guide dog
and he my dog was with me for twelve years he passed away from
God and I swear that when his name was Yahoo.
And. Then I got another dog and she was
lovely is the most beautiful dog in the world. I loved her from the bottom of my
heart. But she she was very playful dog
. She laughs she was Poppy so she was a play on things
and I saw it when this school came Monday following day said to
me she's not a safe dog for you to guide you because she's a
good dog but she's you know not for the blind individual
places. So they took my dog then I after
that decided not to have a dog because emotionally I get very
attached with my dogs they are like a piece of my heart so I
can lead them. So I decided not to have a dog and
I'm doing well with my kids and I travel anywhere with my cane.
Me I prefer subway I don't like buses because stuck in the traffic
all the time and then they tell me
where you want to go and see if you want to visit me and then they
are going to come in as long as you give me that.
Now I'm also.
One of the important important organization
that.
Helped me to grow and develop in my
rights and my education is National Federation of the
blind. I'm the member of the National Federation of the rulers since two thousand and five
and it's unfair for me to be part of it.
It's a wonderful organization is the advocacy
organization for people with disability rights especially people who are vision
loss and have been around for over fifty years
and.
I deceive in a scholarship from the two thousand and five
and he asked me for a moment joined him and I see OK So
in two thousand and five I did see one of the scholarship from him in the New York
state chapter. Then in two thousand and six I received another
scholarship from and I feel a chapter national level
from you know Baltimore.
Maryland. And then.
Those And then after that and that's been a scholarship of another scholarship so I
travel a lot. Besides being in New York I travel different
states I went to Las Vegas and Texas and
Baltimore and Washington D.C. New
Jersey all different states in New
Jersey. Oh I for
Las Vegas I went to a scholarship also from American
consulate love the blind guy was my first scholarship that I won in two thousand and
five in the summer so I went there it was in my scholarship for a
C.B. then I. In two thousand
and five in the fall semester and I received a scholarship from end of the year went to
upstate New York to get Sarah to get my scholarship
and two thousand and six I went to Texas to get my other scholarship from a
farm in the bee and then when I went to Washington D.C.
and Baltimore for leadership seminar
two.
Issues that are mother to blind people to address to
the Congress and Senate. So we went for lobbying.
And I was part of the New York state chapter group so we were
in the lobby to provide electronic books
. For all the line individuals that are going to
colleges students or able to read books because the jet has a print
but blind people are struggling all the time scanning books on
this case until the page and page and page and they have to read
so tense got on with the wonderful
support of our Congress we were able to.
Pass this law now. Every publisher who
published books for the school for college or a school they must
provide electronic. Book with it with the
CD or in me. The format only whatever
to blind people so they'd be able to download it and save it and read it
and study it. So that was one of our great accomplishment
as we did. We also. Fought
about the White King for black people
because they were criticizing the white kid is too long in which people are
tripping on it in this and that and we said this is the tool this is the two black
people have and they're going to have it if you want to trip on its face you know a
consequence of this you know we can change because of
you or. Your the men we have to take care of ourselves. So
those sort of thing we work on in it and another one was about the
target that they have their website very
image a lot our image was and their website and black
people weren't able to access much at Target
in August because of this organization and if be
they the target has been forced to change
their website or web pages and makes it accessible for blind people to
use it.
So. You're done you know
I see you didn't work a number of scholarships and you're currently
working towards to great work.
I finished my master and their fall of two thousand and
nine and two thousand and nine when I graduated in June not
because the graduation ceremonies. Not in the window they have it and some are
so and so what.
What's on the horizon for for your education.
I'm planning to seek a
job. I'm hoping if I can find a job in advocacy.
Positions or and they in human services.
So I mean like right now I'm currently working with the
commission for the blind as well as with the industries where the
applying for jobs employment services to seek job
.
Also my goal is to.
Pursue my Ph D. so I
approach at Columbia University and they have to call a vehicle
college or teaching to go there and pursue my
Ph D. in psychology but they acquired a G.R.
exam so I have to prepare myself for the G.O.P.
He didn't even although I did jury examine five years ago
. But every five years you have to take another G.-O. O.-D. exam so
I have to do it over again and then after that I will see
if I would be able to continue my peach tree. That's my goal. I mean
for education. Yes.
The direction of the organization.
We do it very well we sent we sent about thirty five K.
instable and blind children in Afghanistan into bland high school
.
We send Slayton stylus we send up a seven brave parking machines
. We send them Braille embassador we said no but through thousand
sheets of Braille paper you know the
. Plastic torn off on gray paper that they use in for
special purpose is to do it for you know to draw diagrams
and all so we send that. In. And we are still hoping
that we can to help. Do they have a sports field
that they want to come to leave it there in Afghanistan for the children
. So I'm trying to get involved with the sport
organization here often and services for people with disability
and see if they can help us do.
To you know help the blind school enough Ganesan to
facilities is available for them to
do some work with raising your children here.
No.
No no it's our work is over see I mean the activities the main
offices here. The decision on border safety here but
the work is legal for against I'm not against it and there's a
lot of woman some division in the state of
war. They call me dear Afghan but there are not enough against son
. Unfortunately we cannot help them because they're not in Afghanistan they are
in other countries.
So yes this is not our mission and the weekend. So you know
. What. What advice do you. Have.
For those of us. Here in the US
.
You mentioned night you know challenges you
face. You wish to do in
that situation right.
Well my advice is to first of all believe in
yourself. It's very very important that you have
to believe in yourself because nobody know you well as you
know yourself.
There was a time that I've been always criticized and there wasn't
discrimination don't say oh no you can't make it she's a law
single she can she's not a college material she's this and that
and I prove everyone wrong because what I know myself
I know that if I put my mind something I will I will get it
.
Ice not dancing isn't easy but it's just
I I just you know maybe some Saudi people might
think I'm a stubborn I guess.
Something being is several you know positively I guess how
your life think you.
But then I also the other thing I
suggest.
They are immigrants and they are going to have a disability and they want to be
part of you know it's important if you are in a culture of you need to just
adopt learned their their way of culture learn their
languages you know is necessary and to do that
you need to involve the American people involved with
community learning it is a lot of lot of
opportunities available for free. There you can go and join the
libraries they all these libraries they have English language
classes they can take it. How do you know all of these
they have to already know the three tours and different places that you can go
all the Z.M. or different places to see and
then you learn about the culture and learn also about the language
and if you learn the language and you'll be there. American people are
very wonderful people they are very kind they are very they
brace you they ask you they help you they want to be
to help you as long as you be you know be
persistent and go on with your life and accept your
disability and never be ashamed of it because this is not
something you share. I am very proud to be pro-life and I'm not I'm not consuming myself as a
disabled girl and somehow everybody's disabled
if I have an eye. I don't have I am
disabled. But. You sound how approaching
me right now to do this interview right.
As not mean of you are disabled but do you need my support here
. Right and I and I and this life is life is like
like a Cheney's about bond that bond that bond so nobody can say
you can find anybody say Abel that nobody is able buddy
except God because everybody has some kind.
Of imitation sometime and disability whether it's physical or
mental you know because everybody can be in the same
level. You can be one. How I'm
going to sit you can be. You can be one hundred percent and I
can be a hundred person there's no way a hundred person worked for
everybody. And so somebody has to be ninety nine point
nine nine whatever. So and that's that's the way
life is and I I thing you know we all
. Able bodied am disabled Betty should get
together and make a difference in their communities and their
societies and their own life and their family and
all improved a your own spirit. Because I believe when I go
.
Into their work at least at least I have something to give to the dog I say
God please don't put me into hell because I did something
.
Something good in this or
that background I think you know I
I rather resent your transplant right
here right now. Do you consider yourself a New Yorker. Oh
yeah.
I love New York and love me. Seriously I say I love New York because
of and. The nationalities to know
is. Is that collaboration of different cultures different than we
use. I love New York because if you go down from my
home even is it one o'clock morning I can find something to eat I can plan
something to do and deterrents but they should it is wonderful that train the
subway everything is possible. I mean I love New York because you
know. When I got back from Afghanistan when I came to
the United States I saw all different colors different languages
different is it you know international city and you
never feel you're so isolated for the rest of the community because everybody
has their own culture they have their own language and so is
the United States.
Boat by immigrants and you know and it's
so no matter how American are we going to be you still
. We are and they got this from the other countries. And
. We have to respect both countries. I love America
as a citizen of the United States. I will try my best to be
sincere and honest and offer my services for people who are
in my need as an African-American I'm very
proud to be Afghan woman to offer my help and support to my native
country that I grew up there were born there I will spend my last
twenty nine years of my life there. So.
I love I love to be American New York and
you know it's a good New York is.
So. What's. Next for you
. In. Your work. Where do
you want to work next. So
what's next for you. Well my.
My in my foundation. I'm hoping in the five years
I'll be able to. Help more black people and black children
in Afghanistan. Ideally a whole one two hole to open in another school in
other. Regions of Afghanistan so they can have some kind
of education in my career I'm hoping
I will get a job in some kind advocacy program somewhere
specially for people with disability because that's my major I study
disability studies and this is my major I really want and looking forward
to get some kind of job to help and I will be able to
help them and they will be help me to use my skill and knowledge that I
learned during my massive program. And also Will.
My goal as my education and I'm hoping in five years I will
be me being I don't know five years or three years and four years old my
Ph D. program and. The best of all
I hope I wish I really really hope from
my heart that in the five years you will have a peace in this world
because this war is getting crazy and make me nervous. So
you know life is to short life is to you what you would not
believe if you're going to be surprised at how much life is I never thought I'm going to
become a blinding your mind is that I ran away from my own native
country for the safety to be safe here but I don't know that I'm
going to lose my sight over night and this happen. So life is
beautiful life is you know you need to celebrate your life I
miss now I miss the color of the flower. I miss the
color of the sky. Sometime I really want to see a want to see
in all probably I don't know how what my grand son looked
like I don't know what my grandfather looked like the old woman they are beautiful
gorgeous kids. But I wish if I could. So don't be
sorry where you have you know you know. If you lost so
you have to think that you know if you if you don't work on it you're going
to lose more. So you have to work on it and go on with life
. That's my hope and my hope is I will have peace with the world.
We're going to have help people and I hope with the kindness and
generosity of people I want to say sincerely from the bottom my
heart all my donors all my supporters to support my
foundation does all these years with the monotone or without my meds
are old my fundraising event or anything and I come in here and
help me because they want to help. Others. I'ma just
sit to I have a justice system. I'm not anything they are they
want to help people because they are the one to offer their
financial support I can do with their financial support so I'm
grateful for everybody's support whether it's financially
or emotionally our. Indian education
. I'm grateful for a. Day.
But.
I. Can't thank you enough for sharing your story. There's so much
more that we didn't catch or anything else right.
I want to say it was in there but my mother
my mother.
When I was I think you know this is a culture custom you know when your
kid. Good girl must know how to.
How to do house chores and the boy mass you know how to
bring. In profit or income to the
family that's not that mean that they have to go and nine years old they have to study
but they have to know what is going to be there or they had a
job as an adult. They have to know this is their job they have to bring
income to the family that's it. So when I
was nine or something old we have
been in my in our home that was by I
guess. Has a get so my mother told me go ahead and turn
off the oven so you can we will cook and I told her I can do
this to the little I can do that she said. I know you
can do it just go do it I don't want to have that power in my home. You're not
a coward I know you can do it and so I went and I was scared
but I went and because when my own mother says do it
there's no way I can say no so and I
saw my mother was you know watching me from the corner or
I but she never interfere me so she she
. I did. Turn off the oven then she came she hold me she
hugged me she told me a new area. I told you you can
do it you need to believe in yourself. And that's the
beautiful work. Either. However from my mother
I will always remember believing in myself
so I tell you and through you to your aria and
still be a listener to the public library.
Believing in yourself is is very essential.
It makes me Hugh make you shape your personality
. He give you the you know the whole. He gave you the
authority to stand up for your right to know what is wrong
what is right for you what's wrong for you if you don't believe in yourself you
can do anything. Uneasy believing in yourself and accepting your
disabilities the key for your success.
Thank you Sam Zell. Such an inspiring
story of a match.
This we have this has been you know you're not Janet or visible
as an oral history. That. Is where the New York
Public Library. I have no doubt that your story will be
inspiring.
Thank you thank you very much for me to share it with you
and with the rest of the world and United States disable
individuals
. I love I love all my disable people so
. You know just. Help
. Yourself to help others.
Thank you.